bonjour au versailles bonjour maurice
membre du cncp conseil national des
comités populaires à vous êtes
responsable des affaires extérieures au
sein du cncp votre cb qui apporte son
soutien total dites vous aux candidats
de nous mêmes nos plats mais pour
commencer robert ça et c'est quand trois
candidats en martinique vos porte un
regard sur ce nombre de candidats et
c'est selon vous un signe de la bonne
santé de notre démocratie en afrique où
est cette chose explique d'une part
parce que les partis politiques et leurs
leaders traditionnels ont été dévalués
dans l'opinion publique que l'idée de la
citoyenneté le l'engagement prend de
l'importance
c'est une bonne chose que les gens
souhaitent s'investir
je crois que on ne peut pas se plaindre
d'un nombre important de candidats pour
un choix électoral et puis en même temps
être fâché s'il n'ya pas mille produits
dans un supermarché
on n'a qu'à choisir les bons et puis
c'est ce drôle de parallèle que vous
faites le candidat égale une marque de
lessive par exemple sur les étals de
fabien dire qu'il ya des candidats qui
sont promotionner mieux que des marques
de laisser ce au président macro
actuelle c'est vraiment de la pub qui
l'a amenée ici et qui ça continue encore
si ce nom du marketing efficace en cas
de oui oui mais juste une remarque est
pas au top pour ce qui concerne la
démocratie
on nous oblige à voter le samedi on
cache les résultats sous prétexte de ne
pas influencer l'électorat français
parce que la mise d'accord oui mais là
pour les législatives
quant aux endroits maquereau a remporté
3 10 à une race
c'était formidable chez les français de
l'étranger la dynamique dit sur et de la
propagande 81% de l'abstention et sur le
peu qu'il reste hélas un peu moins que
la moitié attend aussi semblé mais bon
vous semble et envieux vous n'avez pas
su faire ce marketing vous qu'on fait ça
le 9 souffrances aux martiniquais sur la
planète est trop importante pour qu'on
confie des reines du pouvoir a déjà sur
les bases de marketing soit gardée
le fondement des politiques de ces gens
là ça me rappelle les filous dans les
fêtes de quartier avec les deux
cartouches le wall to heaven compte
il prônait une caf ont fait choisir mais
c'est ça je ne déconne pas non non non
non il faut comprendre qu'il y a des
gens qui ont des politiques qui sont
libérés qu'ils vont saccager la nature
qui veut croiser le droit du travail et
qu'on nous présente avec du maquillage
de l'atlantide ses marques même près le
même but pour vous avez en tout cas cela
oui c'est réducteur pour les candidats
tous je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent
que tous les candidats sont pourris il y
en a quelques uns qui se battent
comment faire comment faire la
différence comme en faire une super
basique mais j'ai heureusement tunique
et martiniquaise vous prenez tout cette
kyrielle de gens là qui viennent vous
dire j'aime la santé j'aime les cheveux
je venais la wac est excellent et tioté
y est j sané mois passés à côté il faut
savoir ce que c'est le timing politique
qui veut sa maison mais ils savent
qu'ils ne vont pas le faire
permettez que je peux les clés l'exemple
de la grèce aux législatives si l'isaf
et le tabac ils ont la majorité le
gouvernement dit je vais augmenter les
retraites
je vais mettre des services publics
l'union européenne dit non mais des fois
nous fait ça m'a dit je vous en donne la
bce
la wac est sous l'égide de mai auquel la
bonne amie de ma au conte de mâcon de
bassins de mâcon mais comment ces
candidats -le comme une candidate des
républicains peuvent venir dire j'avais
le check-up le l'augmentation du coût de
la vie
quand elle est pour le libéralisme est
égal je crois que les électeurs les
électrices doivent se baser sur la
pratique rien des gens vrais opposants
dans l'été aux élections vous noterez
pas sur leur programme basic au berceau
reconnaît votre militantisme au sein de
cette organisation politique bien
spécifique vous avez ce que vos
militants aiment bien appeler un niveau
de conscientisation qui n'est peut-être
pas celui du peuple
détrompez vous oui les 80 % des gens qui
s'abstiennent dans les élections c'est
pas des gens
on s'y croyait à baba c'est des gens qui
savaient pas ce qu'ils ont ras-le-bol
dans ses remerciements sont allés aussi
que ces gens là ne servent pas le
réintégrer
parce que d'avoir des prix cassés sur
eux voilà les dieux que nous formons
bichkek mais la baule la folie dans la
volga comme ces cas-là trinel si cons
comment ils ont fait pour résoudre les
problèmes de logement c'est pas avec les
100 logements et annuels que les
services publics a rappelé aux nos
financements et utilisons est glissant
c'est passe par la solidarité par ceux
ci n'avaient pas fait rire mais notre
problème avec des logements qui ne sont
pas aux normes qui risquent de tomber au
moindre vent thomas lary et non la est
en tout cas ainsi que la grille veillera
donc à jodie et s'il fallait compter sur
les politiques publiques du logement les
cent mille habitants de fort de france
ne serait pas là en train de dormir sous
des cabanes gauche comment trouver
comment trouver comment distinguer
comment dénicher ces fameux faux euros
que vous dénoncez dans votre journal du
cncp chic en boutique dès que la
personne vous dit je vais faire je vais
augmenter les autres j'avais donné
milices et où je vais ils savent que ce
n'est pas possible sur le design la
seule qui dira je vais faire je vais
faire mais il faudrait que nous ça passe
et s'est passé au lieu de l'adisq a fait
nous appela dix ans nous organiser en
nous réfléchir aux solutions
et puis le nez plat dit on va organiser
on va ceux ci n'ont pas ce souci c'est
juste ce moment c'est dans la forme que
dans un an ce sont des commerces et mon
peuple organise des ateliers de
réflexion avec des jeunes ingénieur
martiniquais avec des responsables
d'agriculture de pêche pour le bon
qu'est ce qu'il nous faudrait faire pour
appuyer la dynamique citoyenne la
dynamique alternative que nous faisons
déjà bien mal et puis sur les thèmes qui
sont essentiels social l'environnement
comme à l'aller les élus qui sont les
propos des revendications et fera donc à
dessein donc en se mobilisant les
groupes parlementaires
quand vous avez un bon ok et composantes
les donnes ton ou les collectivités m
parlement la salle est vide
reims elle est vide de toute façon le
gouvernement va choisir les intérêts des
viticulteurs des exportateurs français
de ce temps là où je pars de ce qu'est
la liberté de sélection mais j'attendrai
pas les autoriser à aller jusqu'au bout
non j'avais je vais répondre sur cette
affaire-là mais ça veut dire que quand
les gens font un tabac sur le nombre de
postes de député martiniquais et la
serbie c'est du pipeau ouais mais faut
bien qualifier les autres je vais
approcher à dire lors marie-jeanne
letchimy de ne pas s'asseoir à paris
pour discuter des intérêts des
viticulteurs des céréales et phobos et
si facilement qu'à dix enfants
s'intéressent à ce que voulaient de
faire là serait de donner un sacré coup
de main à jean philippe ni l'or qui est
accusé d' absentéisme chronique les
régions qui se base sur une sensation
des politiciens farceur parce que
eux-mêmes vont reprocher à 10 lots de
n'est pas sur le terrain s'il va plus
souvent
et puis ils s'ils se sont d assimiler d
ariane et parce qu'ils savent que c'est
pas comme ça qu'on se fait entendre en
face à face au lobby face aux
multinationales face aux groupes de
pression solidarité de l'ue les publics
à l'eau madame x va dire j'avais fait un
sale guerre défendu fillon je vais faire
les lois républicaines you coûte du
puits de la vie en martinique à baisser
du drapeau à quoi sert une mosson je ne
veux pas personnaliser ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya des gens qui
viennent raconter n'importe quoi quand
nous savons qu'il faut que les gens
s'organisent qui a désintégré content
rires vous avez une minorité de
prédateurs européens qui n'ont qu'une
sorte de philanthropie de sentiments
pour développer la martinique pour
défendre l'écologie etc
ils sont là pour piller et bien nous il
faut qu'on s'organise mon peuple
vous n'êtes pas un peu écrit je suis
enragé contre l'exploitation des gens
qui disent qu'on sa part faire du bateau
mais non mr écoute
tu as des gens et leur fillette qui au
collège comme attaché parlementaire
et puis tu as des retraités qui n'ont
pas de ce groupe où vivent à haïti
non il faut combattre le sida l'indicé
bet avec de robert ça y est le
responsable aux affaires extérieures du
conseil national des comités populaires
merci votre journée merci
[Musique]